هناك أيضًا هذا المقطع
الذي حظي بالكثير من
الاهتمام ومنذ عام 2019 كان في
الجمعية العامة للأمم المتحدة وكان هذا
بين الرئيس زيلينسكي من
أوكرانيا ثم الرئيس ترامب
حيث حث الرئيس السابق
زيلينسكي على محاولة إصلاح
الأمور بشكل أساسي مع فلاديمير  ضع في مشاهدة هذا ،
آمل حقًا أن تجتمع أنت والرئيس
بوتين معًا ويمكن أن تحل
مشكلتك وهذا سيكون إنجازًا هائلاً
وأنا أعلم أنك تحاول فعل
ذلك طوال الوقت الذي تشاهد
فيه وجه zilinski
لأنه شيء  كأن شيئًا ما
يحدث هناك كنت
تغطي أوكرانيا لعقد من الزمان وتغطيه
منذ أن ظهر نوعًا ما على
الساحة ،
ما الذي تراه يحدث هناك
جيدًا ، نعلم جميعًا أننا جميعًا
نشاهد صورًا لما  ما كان على
المحك
في أوكرانيا وفي
مواجهتها مع روسيا
وفلاديمير زيلينسكي هناك ، كان رئيس
أوكرانيا يعلم جيدًا
أنك تعرف إبرام صفقة مع بوتين.
أنت تعلم أن التصالح معه كان
يمكن أن يعني نهاية الاستقلال الأوكراني
لوجودها كدولة
لأنه كان يحذر من أن هذا
ما أرادت روسيا فعله لتدمير
استقلال أوكرانيا واستيعابها
بطريقة ما ولكن هذا
تذكير ب  نوع من الأجواء التي
رأيناها في عام 2019 ، أعتقد أنه كان مناسبًا
مع الرئيس ترامب ثم
الرئيس ترامب نوعًا ما يحاول
نوعًا ما تعرفه أن يعقد صفقة مع بوتين
بطريقة ما تحاول إقناع الآخرين
بتسوية خلافاتهم حتى في
في ذلك الوقت كان هذا في عام 2019 ، كان هذا بعد
ضم شبه جزيرة القرم في عام 2014 وطلب
منه أن يحب بوتين حتى في
ذلك الوقت ، لذلك كان الأمر مجنونًا على وجهه حتى
عندما يجلسون هناك في عام 2019
في سياق اليوم ، إنه أكثر من ذلك بكثير.
يقول أندريه بنشينكو الضارب إن حياته
ستنقسم إلى الأبد قبل
وبعد اليوم الذي جاء فيه الروس
، يتذكر السماء فوق منزله في المضيف
نيكييف الذي غمر فجأة
بالعشرات من طائرات الهليكوبتر الهجومية
يقول إنهم طاروا في تشكيل منخفض
كما لو كانوا في موكب ، وبعد فترة وجيزة
قال إن القوات البرية الروسية اقتربت
من منزله ،
هذا هو المكان الذي يقول إنهم أطلقوا فيه النار
من مسافة على قذيفة متفجرة
سقطت على مقربة من شظايا ساقه
اخترقت الكثير من شظايا ساقه.
لكن أندريه يقول إنه كان محظوظًا لأنه وصل إلى
المستشفى قبل أن يعمل الروس
على قتال الانفصاليين الموالين
لموسكو في شرق أوكرانيا.
أطلق النار أيضًا على
فاسيلي هيلكو أيضًا ، وقد نجا أيضًا من الاحتلال الروسي
ولكن بتكلفة باهظة
، صُدم فاسيلي من الأعداد الروسية
وقوة النيران التي دخلت في
قرية صغيرة شمال شرق العاصمة بوغدانثكي ،
حيث مرت العديد من الدبابات ، وقال إن الكثير من
الذخيرة كان
لكل منزل 20 جنديًا يحتلهم
بما في ذلك المنزل الذي
كان يحتمي به جيرانه وعائلته ،
حيث مكثوا في الطابق السفلي الذي
انتقل إليه الروس فوق
قرية واحدة.  تقول منشأة حزب التحرير إن أربعة
جنود
مخمورين فتحوا باب القبو وصرخوا على الجميع بالعد عشرة أو سيقتلون جميعًا.
لم يبق شيء من ساقه ، كل
العظام تحطمت فقط بركة من الدماء
في دقائق
، كما يقول بعد يومين ، ساعده بعض
الجنود الروس في الوصول إلى المستشفى
لا يزال يعتقد أنهم وحوش وليسوا
أشخاصًا
، قاطع الغزو الروسي للمناطق المحيطة بكيف بعنف وإنهاء
الكثيرين.  حياة الناس
وبعضهم قد ينجو بطريقة ما من
المواجهات الحميمة الوحشية
مما جعلهم يتغيرون إلى الأبد
الآثار الاقتصادية للحرب في
أوكرانيا تنتشر على نطاق واسع
وهذا هو السبب الرئيسي وراء خفض صندوق النقد الدولي
توقعاته للنمو الاقتصادي إلى 3.6
لهذا العام ، ويعكس ذلك  0.8
خفض هذا العام عن آخر
توقعاتهم التي تم إجراؤها فقط في يناير
الآن وليس من المستغرب أن يكون التأثير الأكبر
محسوسًا  في أوكرانيا ، يحذر صندوق النقد الدولي من
انكماش مزدوج الرقم بنسبة 35 في المائة
هذا العام وأن ينكمش اقتصاد روسيا
بأكثر من 8 في المائة ،
لكن كل هذا هو السيناريو الأساسي
إذا كانت العقوبات على روسيا
ستصاعد مع استهداف الطاقة الروسية
وكذلك صندوق النقد الدولي.  يرى
صدمة اقتصادية أكبر بكثير ، فإنه
سيعاقب روسيا بانخفاض إضافي
بمقدار 15 في الناتج المحلي الإجمالي بحلول عام 2027 ،
لكنه سيؤدي أيضًا إلى انخفاض الناتج المحلي الإجمالي العالمي
بنحو 2 في المائة هذا العام فقط مع
استمرار ارتفاع أسعار معادن الطاقة والمواد الغذائية
، وبالنسبة لأوروبا التي تعتمد بشكل كبير  على
الطاقة الروسية يقولون إن التأثير سيكون
كبيرًا مع انخفاض بنسبة ثلاثة في المائة في
الناتج المحلي الإجمالي ،
ولهذا السبب تظل العقوبات على الطاقة الروسية
قضية مثيرة للجدل بالنسبة
للدول الأعضاء في الاتحاد الأوروبي
آنا ستيوارت CNN لندن